- [Voiceover] A total of 72
people participated in a survey
about their music preferences.
The results, separated by
gender, are displayed above.
According to the survey,
what is the probability
that a male likes rap music?
So let's look at the total
number of males surveyed.
So this column right over here,
these are the males that were surveyed.
And we see that the total number
of males surveyed is 35.
So there's 35 males that were asked
what is their musical preference?
And we want to know
what is the probability
that a male likes rap music
according to the survey,
according to the survey.
So out of the 35 males,
how many of them liked rap music?
Well, we see right over
here four out of the 35
liked rap music.
So based on this survey, and
this would really just be
an estimate of the true probability,
but based on this survey, out of 35,
four liked rap music,
so your best estimate
of the probability of a
random male liking rap music
based on this survey,
according to the survey,
would be 4/35ths, or four out of 35.
Now let's look at the choices.
And there we have it, four
out of 35 is actually,
is the first choice.